the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so there's gonna be a mini tutorial on
how to run programs and attach gdb which
is a debugger that's commonly used for
debugging programs will show you how to
debug PPU and SPU programs and it's
going to talk a little bit about some
some other things that might help you in
terms of performance debugging you know
finding out where things are not going
as as well as fast as you might expect
them to do and then next to recitations
which will be next week will focus on
doing some actual performance specific
optimizations so you run your program
it's working well well the functionality
is there but it's not performing as fast
as you might like or you think you can
improve performance a bit better so what
can you do so you'll show you some
tricks and some some things you can do
to get the performance up for some of
you have asked about the Eclipse
debugger and the Eclipse IDE it does run
reasonably slowly on the PlayStation 3
it's because of memory constraints so if
you have lots of people trying to use it
on the Eclipse on the ps3
it'll probably unusable so for those of
you who are interested we'll just do
separate tutorials offline at the diner
other than that all right
so today we'll talk about how to run gdb
on cell and then we'll also do some
static profiling where you can figure
out when instructions are going to be
executed and then I'll talk a little bit
about the dynamic profiling tools that
we have available so you can use gdb to
examine the state of your program and
this can help you figure out bugs that
you might have there's two ways that you
can use gdb the first way is when your
program crashes you can figure out what
was happening at the time that it
crashed another way that you can use gdb
is to kind of run it from the beginning
you attach gdb to your program and then
you step through all the things all the
instructions that are being executed
while the program runs now in order for
gdb to in order for gdb to be able to
provide useful information about the
state of your program you have to give
it a little help you need to compile
your program using GCC - g XL c - g will
also work and they put this puts in
extra information into your this puts in
some extra information into your program
so that when when gdb is looking at the
state of your program it's able to
figure out what line numbers in the
source code that corresponds to so you
can just add - G manually to your GCC in
vacations or you can also set this
compiler or you can set this option in
the make file cc opt level and set that
to CC opt level debug and that will do
the same thing as adding - G alright now
we have a special version of gdb
available for for use on the cell PPU
gdb is used for debugging ppu and SPU
programs after they've been linked
together and how you invoke it if you're
going to if you're going to run your
entire program using gdb is you type PPU
- gdb and
in the name of your program and what you
get is a gdb prompt where you can issue
additional commands to the debugger to
control execution of your program and
also ask it ask the debugger to tell you
various things about your program one
thing you can do is one thing you can do
is export SPU info equals one before you
start your program and that will that
will print some extra debugging
information about when threads are being
created and destroyed like I mentioned
you can also use gdb to attach to a
program that's already running and if
you want to do that you still need to
provide the executable name and you also
provide the process ID of the program to
attach to and
the easiest way to do it is if your
program is running take the top and then
I'll actually show you what's running on
your machine and they'll be a column
that has process IDs so I forgot to
mention if you're if you're invoking
your program with gdb then after you
type PP you gdb with your executable
name
gdb is just going to sit there and wait
for instructions and what you can do is
type run and that will run your program
normally but the difference is that gdb
will pick up and gdb will pick up if see
if something goes wrong and then that's
where you can step in and look at the
program State so what kind of things can
you figure out about your program
anytime you have this gdb prompt and
your program is running you can type BT
to get a to get a stack trace for your
program and this will tell you which
functions are calling which functions
the it's going to give you a list of
frames and the top one is going to
correspond to the deepest level of
function nesting or the deepest function
called in the in the program and of
course the last one on the list is going
to be the main or the first function
that was called that makes sense and for
each for each stack frame gdb will tell
you the name of the function and if
source code is available it will tell
you also which file the function is
running in right now and at which line
number and so using that information you
can figure out exactly you know where it
was that this function called the next
function and where it was that each
function called the the next function
after that
now now whenever you you've halted the
program state you can get information
about what the local variables are and
to do that you can type info locals and
it will print a list of all the local
variables and their values GDP because
it gets annotations from from the
compiled program it knows about what
data types are associated with which
variables and so it will it will be able
to format the values or it will be able
to format the output appropriately so
for example it knows that I is an
integer whereas if you if you had eyes
for example a floating-point number it
would print that a floating-point number
representation instead instead of
looking at single variables you can also
ask gdb to evaluate arbitrary
expressions for you and this is actually
a really powerful facility you can
pretty much type any expression that you
would be able to use in C or C++ when
you type print when you type print var
name gdb will look up that variable name
for you but sometimes if you have more
than one variable if you have if you
have more than one variable available in
your function under the same name for
example these variables are in different
files or different functions on
different functions that are all
available then you may need to
disambiguate the variable name and and
to do that you just precede the variable
name with either of the file name that
you want to use or the function that the
variable occurs in any questions
okay
and because gdb is because gdb knows
which line number which line numbers the
programs is executing right now then
it's able to show you the source code
corresponding to the currents the
current place in the program and in
order to browse the source code if it's
available you just type list in general
whenever gdb has stopped in a certain
place you can type list to get a listing
of you know the source code near that
location and what list will do by
default is show ten lines of source code
near where the program stopped if you
type list again it will show ten lines
following that and you can keep typing
list too to browse the source code you
can also get this you can also get the
code that's that's at a particular line
number if you want to look at another
place in your program alright so this is
how to use gdb to actually control the
flow of your program if you invoke gdb
if you invoke gdb to start up your
program then you can type run and that
will that will run your program with a
normal flow of execution and it will
only stop when when errors occur but you
can use you can use a couple of these
commands to actually go step-by-step
through your program and and wait for
one line to be executed and then you
know decide whether you want to look at
the next line or not if you want to do
this kind of step-by-step execution
you start by used you start by using the
start command instead of the run command
which will run continuously then any
time you want to jump to the next
instruction you you can use Next to get
to the next line in the current
procedure you can also use step which
will if there are function calls on the
current line it will descend into those
function calls and show you what's going
on over there
and if you're inside a function call you
can type finish in order to in order to
jump back to right after the function
call ends in the in the caller of that
and if you want to stop if you want to
stop line by line execution you can type
continue and it will just continue
without interruptions any questions
basically any time you use one of these
line by line commands gdb will show you
the line that you're on and if the if
the if your program just jumped into a
new function or something then it will
also show you what function and what
file you're in so this is very helpful
for following what's going on in your
program okay so in addition to just
running through your program
step-by-step you can also choose to only
stop your program when certain things
happen so this is very useful for
debugging you know certain pieces of
code where the code is very deeply
nested inside and you don't want to you
know step all the way to there you just
want to stop when you get there and GDP
allows you to define breakpoints which
are places in your source code and once
gdb once gdb gets to a point of
execution which corresponds to that
point in your source code it will stop
and ask you what to do you can set a
breakpoint that's associated with any
particular function in your source code
or any particular well what you can do
is if you do break function then it will
create a new breakpoint and it will stop
execution anytime you get to the
beginning of the beginning of that
function but you can also set
breakpoints in the interior of a
function by using line numbers all right
any questions
now sometimes sometimes you want a
little bit more flexibility than that in
setting breakpoints suppose you if you
only want to set a breakpoint to happen
when a certain condition is true this is
helpful if you're trying to kind of
track down a bug then you can right
break and any of these things and then
if expression and again you can use any
sort of expression that you would be
able to use in C and what gdb will do is
every time execution runs up to that
line it will evaluate the expression and
only if that expression is true will it
will it stop to ask you for control it
means at any time you can see which
breakpoints are active by doing info
breakpoints at the gdb prompt and you
can also remove breakpoints at any time
when each breakpoint is created it's
given this it's given this number and
the numbers start from one and to remove
a break point you just do remove
followed by the number that was assigned
in addition to breaking you can also set
a watch point what this does is it will
halt your program every time a
particular value changes and this is
this is useful for tracking down certain
kinds of bugs if you're looking if
you're trying to figure out where a
certain value for a variable came from
there could potentially be many many
places in your program where that value
is set and you don't want to have to set
a breakpoint for all of those and and
watch them so you can instead set a
watch point which will just tell you
when that value is set watch points work
a lot like break points and you can if
you do info breakpoints it will also
list the watch points and I believe you
can also remove them the same way with
remove
all right so I mentioned how you can
examine your program state by looking at
the values of local variables if you
want a more low-level view of what's
going on in your program you can
actually look at the raw you can
actually look at the raw memory and gdb
allows you to specify an address and it
will tell you exactly exactly what data
is stored in the memory at that address
but because there's not necessarily
annotation info telling gdb what kind of
data is stored at that address and of
course there's multiple ways you can
interpret any particular piece of data
you'll have to tell gdb exactly how you
want that data to be interpreted so you
can interpret any particular block of
memory as for example a series of
machine instructions then gdb will tell
you what the instructions are as if you
were looking at as if you were looking
at an assembly listing you can ask gdb
to interpret the memory as if it were an
array of an array of integers and print
them out either in hex or in decimal
you can ask gdb to - to display the
program or display the data as if they
were addresses or floating-point numbers
and how you do this is you type X for
examine memory and slash and then the
number following is the number of words
you want to look at and then the letter
corresponds to one of these letters and
tells gdb how to format the output and
then the address will be the starting
block of where you want to start
examining memory all right any questions
about this
okay so I mentioned that at any time
when you stop your program there are
going to be multiple function calls
which are active corresponding to you
know main which call this other function
which call this other function which
called wherever your current point of
execution is and you can actually
examine the state for all of these all
of these stack frames separately when
you do when you do BT it's going to give
you the list of frames right and they're
going to be numbered from 0 to however
many however many there are and you can
jump to you can jump to you can jump to
any of them by using frame and the
appropriate number and it's going to
default to frame 0 which is the closest
to where your program is actually
executing but you can examine the state
in frames which are further away so that
means when you're evaluating variables
each variable only makes sense in the
context of a particular frame and you're
able to go up the call stack to figure
out you know what the value what the
value of a particular variable is in
this function which call this other
function you can also use the commands
up and down to just jump to the
immediately adjacent frames all right
okay so you can use GDB from Emacs as
well and Emacs provides a really handy
interface for gdb if you do MX gdb Emacs
will invoke gdb for you and you're going
to want to when you do this you're going
to want to tell Emacs to use PPU gdb
instead of regular gdb and Emacs will
just ask you what you want to invoke you
just want to replace gdb with ppyou gdb
anytime you're you anytime you're
debugging within Emacs if Emacs has your
source code files open it will show you
the current point of execution by
drawing a little arrow next to the
particular line next to the particular
line in the buffer you also get a bunch
of keyboard shortcuts that you can use
to do some common operations you can set
breakpoints with control X space just by
just by placing your cursor at the
particular line that you want to stop in
so you don't have to so you don't have
to go to gdb and type break whatever
whatever but when you do MX gdb in Emacs
you get a separate buffer for gdb and so
you can issue all the commands that you
normally would want to okay so the first
thing we're gonna try this should be
really quick is we're just going to is
we're just going to open up a brief
program and make sure you can invoke gdb
on it
oh and you'll have to set a cell top if
you don't have that said already
I'm single I'm single
oh you can do quit or control-d
so once once you've attached gdb to a
program when you exit gdb it will quit
the program that you were running unless
you do detach first for this one it
doesn't really matter because we're
looking at a crash anyway
you can evaluate an expression using
print okay any questions all right so
all I did here was run and then the
program crashes this is just a lab one
without this is just lab one without the
alignment in the control block that you
need to to make everything work
correctly and so all I did here was run
and then the program crashes and then
prints CV and of course this thing is
going to be 0 because the DMA transfer
to do that doesn't work
questions ok so we can exit the debugger
with control D and it'll ask if you want
to kill the program ok
so GDP also has features to help you
with debugging programs that have
multiple threads whenever a new thread
is is created or just whatever new
thread is created or thread is destroyed
gdb will print a brief message to tell
you and one important thing is it will
print this lwp number on the
Playstations and ok so to get a list of
threads you can type in foe threads and
gdb always maintains this thing called
the current thread and by default when
you do many other many of these other
actions they're going to apply to the
current thread and so to examine things
about other threads you're gonna have to
change the thread and to do that you do
thread and some number when you do info
threads it's going to give you this list
of threads which are numbered for
example 1 2 3 on the left and the lwp
numbers that are displayed are going to
correspond to these that came up when
the threads were started but you're
gonna have to use these numbers on the
left to switch between threads and when
you do info threads gdb will mark the
current thread with a star on the left
and we'll also show you where each
thread is executing right now questions
it will show the procedure and the
filename and line number if that if that
information is available No
Betina
sorry
so David said maybe you can do it on
simulator ok so we're going to try this
brief exercise which is just to get you
to work with dealing with multiple
threads and what you're going to do is
load the lab 1 program which is the
correctly working solution for lab 1 and
if you'll recall this program has
multiple threads the PPU thread
maintains an array of control blocks and
it's going to send the addresses of
those control blocks to the SPU's so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to set breakpoints at the right
places to verify that the that the first
SPU thread is getting a control block
the the control block which is the same
as one of the control blocks in the PPU
program all right any questions about
that this is in rec for lab 1 so you're
going to have to run and set breakpoints
at the right places and you're going to
want to set one breakpoint in each
thread to be able to examine the value
of C B that's that's being produced
here we have two three
right after presentation as in there's
another exercise for those of you did
get through the way you'll actually run
into these problems is you run your
program and you might end up with a bus
error so you might want to do is then
launch gdb and you run to the error and
then you trace back in execution to see
is my control block value matching so
you might want to try that at the second
exercise offline should we do the stack
profiling so one problem that you may
have run into is that gdb will remove
breakpoints from threads that exit which
is a problem if you have more than one
thread running the same program and if
you're debugging SPU programs gdb may
complain about not being able to find
the source files but if you just if you
just ignore that message it seems to
find them okay I think you can use SPU
gdb to debug the SPU programs by
themselves you can try that sometime
okay so actually figuring out what the
errors are unfortunately you don't get
very much information from the actual
errors that occur but maybe looking at
where the errors are occurring can help
you figure things out if you've run into
memory misalignment problems or the
problem in the last recitation where we
had DMA transfers that were too big
those are all going to be bus errors
under various other circumstances you
might get segmentation faults and if you
think your program is running into a
deadlock you can also use gdb to kind of
attach to the program and then examine
the state of that program to see you
know what's waiting for what okay so
static profiling we have some tools for
the cell that will allow you to we have
some tools for the cell that will allow
you to when you have a sequence of
assembly instructions figure out kind of
when those instructions are going to get
scheduled and how fast the resulting
sequence will run so in order to take
advantage of this you need to use GCC -
big s to generate your assembly and you
can also do that with Excel C if you're
using our make files you can also use
make whatever file name dot s in order
to generate the assembly from your from
your source code then once you have the
dot s file you can run this utility
called SPU timing and one SPU timing is
what SPU timing does is it will take all
the instructions that n that are in your
assembly and figure out the dependencies
between them and then it will figure out
when the earliest point is that each
instruction can get executed and it will
print out the schedule that that's
generated so if you provide the -
running count option then it will also
show you how many cycles the how many
cycles in all the entire program will
take and the output goes into file name
dot s dot timing
so for how instructions are scheduled on
sell if you'll recall there's if you're
if you'll recall there's two pipelines
for different kinds of instructions and
some instructions can only run on one or
the other of the pipelines and some
instructions can run on both now
now how sell actually schedules those
instructions is it's always going to go
in order that the instructions are
specified in the in the in the binary
and whenever there's two instructions
next to each other which whenever
there's two instructions next to each
other and the first instruction can run
on pipeline zero and the second
instruction can run on pipeline pipeline
one then sell we'll try and schedule
those at the same time and that's called
dual issue so if you are taking
advantage of that dual issue all the
time then potentially you could schedule
two instructions every cycle oh yes and
and unlike a lot of other architectures
nowadays cell does not have dynamic rent
branch prediction all the branch
prediction is encoded inside the all the
branch prediction is encoded inside the
assembly that you that you're using so
that means for for any type of loop or
whatever you you have to be sure to get
the branch prediction right if the if
the branch prediction is wrong cell is
going to end up prefetching instructions
along the wrong line and it's going to
have to stall by about 20 cycles when
when you figure out when it figures out
that the branch is wrong
so if you're looking at the generated
assembly on cell all the instructors are
going to be of the form operation then
the destination register and then two or
more sources and if you're trying to
figure out if you're trying to just kind
of orient yourself in the generated
assembly there sometimes these these
helpful these helpful markers so if
you're looking at if you're looking at
the generated assembly for dis to SPU
then it's going to have a header at the
top which says which files were included
inside this which the files were
included inside this file and then where
the actual assembly is there will be
these markers that say for example
location 119 and what this means is that
here is the assembly corresponding to
file one line nineteen so that's kind of
helpful if you're trying to get your
bearings inside the assembly because
otherwise it's really hard to make heads
or tails of questions alright so after
you actually run your assembly through
the static profiler it will spit out
this schedule and what the schedule
shows is which is which clock cycles are
used for every single instruction
there's one line for each assembly
instruction and what it's going to do is
it's going to print one digit in this
schedule for each cycle that the
instruction takes alright so so you can
kind of think of this this dimension as
the passage of time and what happens is
that these guys when they get to the
right-hand side they'll wrap around at
50 columns or whatever and and you'll be
able to notice you know when these
instructions are being scheduled and
sometimes because sometimes when there's
dependencies between instructions the
instructions are not able are not able
to get scheduled at the at the earliest
possible time and when that happens
you'll see these dashes which mean that
the instruction is being stalled to wait
for one of the dependencies in order to
make your code fast you're going to want
to eliminate these eliminate these
stalls
and you can do that to a large extent by
reordering your instructions
so the point of instruction scheduling
is going to be to to minimize the number
of stalls and and you can you can do
that by if you have instructions which
are going to be dependencies for other
instructions you just want to move those
as far up as you can instructions per
cycle or how many instructions to use
your per cycle to because you have two
pipelines or so how many cycles per
instruction they would be but I have
because you're getting two structures
per cycle so we have an exercise that
actually has you understanding the
assembly code and then doing the
instruction reordering so we'll leave
that on slides you can do it offline but
we'll pick up with this next week and go
over instruction scheduling some DMA
tricks for improving performance and the
particular thing will focus on quite
rigorously hits this invitation so Phil
is going to walk you through how to get
listen guys you get performance from the
vectorization
Indian Trenton's and we'll talk a little
bit about the dynamic profiling and for
those of you who are still having
problems with gdb
we'll try to resolve those now since
they'll probably be very useful for your
projects and we installed CBS in the
main directory on every ps3 for those of
you who actually want to use
and go through the trouble of setting up
their own CVS the CVS is satisfied
actually notify the local users on that
machines that are B everybody in their
team it'll send out an email whenever
somebody does a check-in or an import to
let them know that there's some new for
making the thing long one cupcake if you
don't know how to use CVS so we want to
put two toriel to stop by somebody T as
well help you okay